У мене чарівне прізвище – Бартосік.
БАРТОСІК : багатство, амбіція, розум, талант, освіченість, сила –
ілюструються культурою.
Я хотів створити тут культурний осередок, і це те головне,
що я хочу, щоб воно без мене,
незалежно на якому етапі, якого дня і часу
я пропаду, а воно повинно розвиватись далі.
От запропонували такий
художній салон-студію – магазин «Сінот-бар».
Це середовище – ще не завершене,
але вже виконує свою пряму функцію –
тут відбуваються культурні події якісь.
У нас будівля символічно поділена на три рівні.
Є середній поверх – де ми заходимо, купляємо хлібчик,
до хлібчика і так далі.
Є нижній поверх, пекло так зване.
Туди спускаються люди щось випити міцніше,
просто поспілкуватись
але воно там і оформлене,
там чортики всякі і так далі ходять.
І є рівень — ось.
Це той, до якого всі повинні нібито прагнути.
Він вищий рівень, тут вже твориться щось
не дуже матеріальне, тобто це наші ідеї матеріалізовані.
Зустріч: чоловічок прийшов у відпустку
і найперше він засумував за своєю другою половинкою,
обійми і так далі, а донька притулилася до «татика»,
і вона ображена, вона ображена на тата,
що він перевагу віддав мамі, а не їй.
Мама тримає землю,
а тато на плечах тримає небеса,
щоб небеса не звалились на землю
і нас не передавили, скажемо так.
Автору ніколи не приємно пояснювати свою роботу.
Завжди хочеться, щоб люди
самі це якось розуміли, читали.
І як мені потім буває соромно, коли людина відкрила
для мене щось вище, ніж я туди закладав.
Я від цієї хатинки в захваті.
Здавалося б – просто колона?
Так, просто колона.
Ще не закінчено, але я хотів би, щоб це хтось бачив
і брав це як основу і розвивав.
Що це?
Так, це латумна гайка.
Сюди під'єднюється рукав пилососа.
Пилосос сам потужненький промисловий стоїть на дворі,
під'єднується, і пилюка залишається на дворі, а не в хаті.
Є санвузол, є умивальник, є душова,
і для економії простору поличка зроблена на дві частини.
Вона може і там використовуватись і тут використовуватись.
Оце, що це таке?
Композиція – котик з мишкою.
Але воно відкривається: і тут є праска, все є, так?
Що це? Це ж ми розуміємо, що це дзеркальце, так?
Ми розуміємо, що це стільчик,
і ми ж всі прекрасно розуміємо,
що це косметичка.
То ось так треба підходити,
що в одному «санвузлику» кілька таких речей.
Мама, дружина, мама двох дітей,
прекрасна, турботлива.
— Дякую за хороші слова.
— Знайомтесь.
Аня і Аня.
І бабуся в неї теж була Аня.
Так, по татовій лінії, так.
Цю роботу я робила, мабуть, на першому курсі в академії.
В принципі, я її робила на подарунок для мами.
Хотілося передати цю материнську ніжність,
дитячу ніжність.
Робота може бути динамічною, може бути статичною,
але якщо немає там драми, то і немає роботи.
Вона нікому не буде цікава.
Є робота, що зроблена в салон,
під кон'юнктуру, так, виконана.
Творча робота – вона навпаки,
автор копається в собі, і оце нутро:
чимдуж він його проявить, виверне із себе,
вона не буде подобатись загалу.
Але коли найдуться хоч одиниці, які в унісон мислять
з автором, то для автора то – найцінніше.
А таких людей не може бути багато.
Є чоловіче і жіноче начало, є цей Всесвіт і
є оця мить, мить, яка при зустрічі породжує вічність.
Для когось це шматок дерева,
хтось в ньому бачить дельфіна.
Та ця дерев'яха цінна тим, що це  – яблуня,
вона росла на батьковому подвір'ї, біля хати.
Девіз моїх батьків: «На мій вік вистачить»,
ось вони до всього так ставились.
У мене девіз інакший.
Я хочу,  щоб від мене залишилось.
Тихомир, Тихомир, Тихомир, ходи сюди, ходи.
Оце – наш центр, так?
А це наш центр, нашого мікрокосмосу, мікровсесвіту.
З цього в нас все починається.
Це моя дипломна робота,
називається – «Пошук рівноваги».
Ідею закладала таку, що було видно не тільки
фізичний пошук а, власне, і життєвий,
що ти постійно вагаєшся,
не знаєш, в яку сторону тебе закине,
і ти маєш встояти і все-таки вирішити
куди ступити у своєму житті.
Це взагалі не примітне місце,
а з нього виросла гігантська будівля.
Ось, якось так.